shooting stabbing and plenty of slick
suits what else can you expect from a
john wick movie
john wick has a painful past he used to
work for the biggest gangsters in the
country killing people left and right
and developing a fearsome reputation in
the process but eventually john tired of
his violent life and after tying the
knot he retired from the assassin
business for good
retirement however is far from smooth
sailing though the first john wick movie
opens with our hero having recently lost
his wife to a terminal illness his dog
who was gifted to him by his wife is
soon killed by joseph the son of a mob
boss
thus john embarks on a crusade of
vengeance bringing his artillery out to
once again become one of the most
dreaded assassins in the world in the
second movie jon crosses paths with
another mob boss santino d'antonio who
double crosses him this propels the
titular protagonist on a fresh mission
of revenge but jon's actions in john
wick 2 put a mark on his head and the
third movie is all about him becoming a
wanted man the film ends with jon once
again swearing bloody revenge against
anyone who tries to cross him whoever
comes
whoever it is
i'll kill them
i'll kill them all
this reputation for being an unstoppable
killing machine follows john across
every movie to the point where you are
left wondering why anyone would even
bother to try to get in his way
on the surface the john wick movies
appear to have pretty basic plots
but the storyline actually goes pretty
deep and it all connects back to jon's
past as a master assassin working for
the mob throughout the trilogy audiences
catch glimpses of a secret world of
assassins that operates by its own set
of rules it has its own currency in the
form of gold coins and a strict code of
conduct the entire criminal network is
run by a secret group of power brokers
called the high table and at the heart
of it all the various continental hotels
appear to be the place where the people
in charge of this world congregate and
arrange their missions
some answers about this secret world
will be provided in the upcoming
continental hotel spin-off tv series
which will focus on the creation of the
establishment and its assassin clientele
john wick is often considered one of the
most badass anti-heroes ever put to film
every person who crosses his path who
knows anything about his past is
absolutely terrified of him the best
example of this occurs in one of the
most iconic scenes in the franchise
which takes place in the first john wick
movie joseph the guy who had killed
jon's dog does not understand the depth
of his mistake and so his mob boss
father patiently explains to him that
jon is known as baba yega in the
assassins world aka the boogeyman
although as explained in the film he
wasn't necessarily the boogeyman himself
he was the one you sent to kill the
[ __ ] pokemon
there are very few people whom jon can
trust to help him without them expecting
anything in return chief among them is
winston the manager of the new york
continental hotel winston holds enormous
influence in the world of assassins and
he has used that influence on multiple
occasions to help jon out of respect for
their shared past in the first movie
winston allows jon to temporarily take
cover at his hotel and also provides
information about the mob boss mr wick
had set out to kill in the second movie
winston personally steps in to delay the
placing of an excommunicado title on
jon's head which would have every
assassin in the country gunning for him
then in the third movie things escalate
to the point where winston teams up with
jon to go against the high table and
bring down the assassin world's power
structure once and for all
audiences get to see plenty of examples
of john's ability to kill his target no
matter the obstacle while he prefers to
make use of guns and knives mr wick is
also not above using any hard object
that happens to be nearby to give his
enemies all sorts of imaginative and
brutal deaths for instance the first
film's mob boss explains to his son that
jon once single-handedly killed three
men in a bar using a pencil and we see
this method of murder in action in the
second film in the third film when jon
faces a towering opponent in a library
he uses a thick book to break the guy's
jaw and shatter his fine then there were
the horses that jon sticked onto his
enemies later in the film basically bad
guys should feel lucky if he shoots them
because the alternative is a lot more
drawn out and messy what put the john
wick series on the map was the industry
changing level of sophistication of its
action sequences the franchise was
conceived by screenwriter derek colstad
alongside david leach and chad stahlski
two men who had been top stuntmen and
second unit directors for years and you
can see the level of expertise they
bring to the table as directors while
other action movies use every trick in
the book to hide the fact that the lead
actor is not actually doing the stunts
themselves keanu reeves trained heavily
to be able to do as many of the stunts
on camera as possible as matt patches
wrote for grant land stahelski and leach
were blunt with their star john wick
would not involve anything reeves had
done before he would learn judo japanese
jiu jitsu and brazilian jiu jitsu from
some of the toughest guys stzelsky and
leech ever met this allowed the
directors to let complicated fight
choreography play out without needing to
switch to a double for his part reeves
told cinemablend that he does about 90
of the action himself
as a man constantly on the run there are
not a lot of places where john wick can
feel safe and at home
one place that keeps popping up in the
franchise as a safe haven for even the
most desperate individuals is the series
of continental hotels one of which is
run by jon's old friend winston the
assassin world revolves around these
hotels and winston wields enough
influence to make sure none of the
assassins or mob bosses ever dare get
into a fight while on the premises in
the third movie winston plots with jon
to completely upend the balance of power
in the assassin world by taking out the
high table the hotel becomes the setting
for an epic third act shootout that ends
with jon faking his death and winston
being reigned in by the adjudicator
once jon re-entered the world of
assassins other characters often begged
and pleaded for him to give up his
mission of vengeance and return home and
he refused every time forging forward
resolutely to punish those who had
destroyed his last chance at anything
resembling peace and happiness you're
not very good at retiring
i'm working on it
as reeves told the austin chronicle for
me it was fun telling this mythological
old testament revenge tale but i don't
quite think of it as revenge i think of
it as reclaiming jon's will to exact
vengeance is the character's defining
trait it's also what makes him such a
compelling protagonist whom you cannot
help but root for
for john wick and the rest of the
criminal underworld killing each other
in the line of business is perfectly
acceptable but breaking a promise is the
most despicable sort of behavior it's
strange that in a world where promises
and oaths are literally the currency
characters are bound to break them all
the time in the first movie the sanctity
of john's retirement is shattered which
kicks off his journey through the series
in the second movie santino breaks the
rules of their agreement prompting jon
in turn to flout the continental's rules
by killing him on hotel property the
third movie shows us the consequences of
jon's actions and everyone who helped
him the high table physically punishes
winston and the bowery king and then
forces them to resign from their
positions of authority in the meantime
jon had made a promise to kill winston
personally a promise he later walked
back on consequently starting a war with
the high table on one side and jon the
bowery king and winston on the other
when we first meet jon in the original
movie he's dressed in an unkempt manner
befitting his status as a grieving
widower but once the action starts he
puts on his iconic black suit that helps
him conceal his weapons the men that jon
fights in all three movies are also
always faultlessly dressed in the most
fashionable clothes found in high
society but the suits worn by keanu
reeves in the films are far more
complicated than regular business
clothes john wick costume designer luca
mosca tells gentlemen's journal there
are so many secrets in the suits safety
always comes first so i often had to
allow room for pads and anything else
keanu had to wear to protect himself
during stunts or fight scenes
john wick is one of the most violent
action heroes in modern cinema but
audiences still love rooting for the guy
that is because he operates by a strict
code of honor among allies and enemies
alike are you here on business sir
great sir francis
why don't you take the night off
we first glimpse jon's code in the first
movie when he offers to let the main
villain and his men off the hook if they
simply hand over the guy who killed his
dog it's only when the criminals refuse
his offer that jon goes bogeyman on
their butts in the second movie he is
unwillingly dragged back into action to
honor a pledge he made to another crime
boss years ago in the third film we see
jon calling in favors with the gold
coins used as currency in the secret
assassin world
these coins are the best example of the
code that the assassins live by a token
of acknowledgement for services rendered
and a debt that will need to be repaid
at some point in the future his code of
honor also determines who he lets live
or die if he respects a fellow assassin
enough even if they're trying to kill
him he might leave them with their
injuries rather than finish the job
what sets john wick apart from other
action heroes in the genre is the fact
that you can clearly see his many
violent encounters take a toll on his
body he is punched kicked shot at and
stabbed many times leaving him bloodied
and struggling to stand upright by the
end of each movie he even cuts off a
finger in the third film and a leader is
shot multiple times point blank and
dives backward off the roof while jon
always manages to walk away from his
violent encounters in the end the blood
and scars on his face are a grim
reminder of the price he has to pay to
keep forging his path toward absolution
those types of injuries help keep the
tension high among audiences as they are
left wondering how long john's body can
take such heavy abuse without breaking
down once and for all
it could be hard to keep rooting for
john wick if the films did not regularly
remind us of his loving nurturing side
buried deep within the events of the
first film are a direct result of the
deep love he had for his deceased wife
helen the second movie shows her in a
brief flashback that once again affirms
the powerful love jon felt for his wife
and how that love made him want to
become a better man the third movie does
not feature any appearances by helen but
we see jon going to retrieve a picture
of her in preparation for leaving the
country these moments help solidify the
idea that as awful a person as john wake
is forced to be in his dealings with his
enemies he still yearns for the life of
companionship he shared with helen once
upon a time
[Music]